how old were you when you got the mtv
show like 16.
uh i was just turning 17. so we went
through the whole like doing the um
you know doing the pilot episode uh it
was yeah i
just turned 17 when they actually were
like okay we're we're gonna do this
and uh we want three seasons and
at that point like i didn't really know
much about television but i figured
three seasons is pretty good and
uh we have something good yeah we have
you know we have fun you know but it was
a super controversial time in my life
um because i was known as like a contest
skater
i had a couple video parts and
i was doing really well like i was i was
known as a skateboarder
and then this opportunity came up where
we were already like flying crazy places
like flying private and you know having
parties and having fun
but still winning the contest and they
picked up on that and like the dynamic
between me and my family and me and my
friends was like
it was entertaining it was definitely
entertaining and they wanted it and uh
so we did it and the first season was
awesome man we were getting like 2.6
million viewers
per episode roughly we're on friday
night at like 10 o'clock so it was like
and that's when you had to like
sit at home and watch tv you know it
wasn't like no social media or anything
like that we were actually getting like
two million
you know authentic views which was crazy
and so
mtv ate it up i ended up too because it
was like now all of a sudden we're like
have budget to actually go take a
private plane to a contest which was
crazy
showing up at a contest with four camera
guys and you know the pas and the sound
guys and like we had
a posse deep of 25 always so it was it
was just a scene you know and
um did the show but
in the actual skateboarding community it
caused a little bit of a
like uproar you know like people were
truly convinced that i was like
destroying skateboarding and
my whole thing was like man
skateboarding's such a freedom
and it's based on how you feel on your
board how i feel on my board it's such
an individual sport that like not one
person can destroy something that's so
pure and so like free for everyone
yeah and what were you destroying about
that's just people being haters
you know yeah and i realized that now
you know i'm 30 now and it's it's crazy
thinking that
you know the show was 12 years ago 13
years ago
what was i destroying i i don't know at
that point i couldn't even tell man
all i thought was that i was introducing
introducing skateboarding to kids that
would have never
otherwise picked it up or even were
curious about it you know but they were
watching mtv
so they saw it you know and i don't know
man it was a weird time but i
i don't regret it at all you know if
anything it
it's created such an incredible fan base
for me that that has stuck around
since i was a kid and you know it it was
a show before
it got it wasn't a crazy show you know
yeah there was drama and there was
things of that nature but i always kept
my
my morals and and how i wanted my
family to be treated i kept that super
straight the whole time and i treated my
family with the utmost respect and
especially like
dude mtv's wet dream was my parents
getting a divorce
on the show you know and i had no idea
that was gonna happen
i couldn't even see it coming honestly
and uh
yeah my parents split up and uh i was
destroyed bro
i was destroyed and so that was you know
what what season was that oh i'm sorry
yeah
uh that would have been like end of it
might have been in the second season
so you're like 18 when your parents
split no i was uh in
my parents split when i was 17. so i had
i had like four months left of being 17
to like by i just remember because i
wanted to move out immediately
you know like they got divorced and i
wanted out because of that
yeah how much time was in between
filming seasons would you like film a
season then you're off
for like nine months and then again or
you just kept filming back
we filmed back to back yeah it was all
back that's how we got three seasons
done before i was even 19.
right and by the third season i was um i
was over it
you know i was just over it it was crazy
of like
you know how it goes dude like i was
waking up to three cameras
almost every day and it was like a
monday through friday thing
and then you know having to like reshoot
breaking up with girls that i really
cared about you know
right yeah oh my god so you broke up
with a girl and they were like
can we get that again one more yeah and
i haven't that happened twice dude and i
was like man
[ __ ] this dude like oh my god were you
like are you serious are you like
contractually you have to
i mean i didn't even know if it was
contractually i wasn't even thinking
like that
then i was just like man i guess if it's
like [ __ ]
so i would like take the mic off go
explain
to my girlfriend what had just happened
and like still we're breaking up like
we're broke up
but i need you to be a team player and
like i need you to be a team
player you gotta break up again who
broke up with who you broke up with i
had to break i was always breaking up
with the girls [ __ ]
yeah man man it was rough dude it was
rough it was rough for sure
but you know i don't take any of it for
granted it was a it was a wild
experience you know it definitely shaped
a lot of of who i am today and
experiences that i somewhat don't want
to get back into i've been offered to do
a tv show again i'm like nah you know
like i'm working on our own things in
here doing the sandlot time so it's like
it's a lot more fun and it's a lot more
100 of our control that's the main thing
we need to have control of what we're
what we're putting out
yeah dude